today the council gave its assessment to
the work done on the field of transport
under the Estonian presidency back in
June with the Commission presented its
first mobility package the biggest
transport initiative of the Unocal
Commission the council recognized that
significant progress has been made with
regulating access to market we have also
moved closer to the range agreement on
the more harmonized European market for
hire vehicles
there have been important steps forward
on driving and rest time rules of the
drivers transport is about people and
today we discussed the number of points
of interest for EU citizens and new
workers first the Commission's proposal
to improve the functioning of a road
toiler market and improve social and
employment conditions second point the
future of road charging in Europe in May
we proposed to modernize row charging to
better tackle the external cost of road
transport today we had a debate which
showed that many member states support
the idea of smart road charging the
council took stock of the progress made
on the proposal on safeguarding
competition in air transport and it aims
to ensure fair competition between new
airlines and third country carriers
while maintaining a high level of air
connectivity throughout europe finally I
would like to underline that the Council
adopted three sets of conclusions first
on the digital transport second on the
implementation of 20 network and the
safe instrument and third on the midterm
review of Galileo and EGNOS these three
conclusions set a forward-looking vision
for the innovative competitive and
multimodal transport system for Europe